madame monsieur bonsoir aussi les titres
de l'actualité de ce jeudi 1er mai cinq
français ont été tuées dans les alpes
italiennes par une avalanche en 6e leur
guide rescapé miraculeusement est
toujours à l'hôpital en état de choc les
cinq personnes décédées quatre hommes et
une femme ont été retrouvés en cordée
les manifestations du 1er mai à paris en
province lancent en moi qui devrait être
placée sous le signe de la revendication
avec plusieurs journées d'action cet
après midi en fait de fortage se trouver
l'un des salariés sans papiers qui a
reçu parmi les premiers son document de
régularisation polémique en italie après
la publication sur internet de toutes
les déclarations d'impôts des citoyens
célèbres stars du cinéma de l'industrie
de la mode le site vite saturé a été
finalement fermée celle agences des
impôts qui a pris cette initiative
parmi les métiers particulièrement
difficile où le taux d'accidents du
travail est très élevé celui de marins
pêcheurs selon les chiffres officiels un
sur huit et victimes chaque année
d'accident du travail mais crise
économique oblige il sort ce temps mer y
compris dans des conditions difficiles
le mont saint michel fait aujourd'hui
avec une ferveur toute particulière ses
1300 ans fondée en l'an 968 par les
bénédictins
le mot est d'abord un lieu religieux
avant d'être un site touristique inscrit
au patrimoine de l'humanité et six
alpinistes français qui se trouvaient
dans les alpes italiennes 3000 mètres
d'altitude auraient été victimes d'une
avalanche qui les auraient projeté
contre une barre rocheuse hier après
midi dans des conditions météorologiques
particulièrement difficiles il avait
tout de même choisi d'effectuer cette
sortie en montagne
cinq ont été retrouvés morts toujours
encore dès le 6e qui a pu être secouru
hier soir est toujours à l'hôpital
originaire de savoie il était guide
depuis 20 ans et d'après ses collègues
extrêmement expérimenté reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux denis sébastien et jean
claude martin il est environ 7 heures ce
matin les secours viennent de reprendre
les recherches
nous sommes à près de 3000 mètres
d'altitude sur un itinéraire classique
de ski de randonnée
rapidement les cinq disparus sont
retrouvés malheureusement tous décédés
ils étaient en partie enfouie sous la
neige tout son corps d vous avez dû
creuser pour les retrouver au mdp
pourquoi nous avons vu le cleee le sac
et après ils sont avec l'hélicoptère
pour reporter de profondes
l'alerté avait été donnée hier en fin
d'après midi par un gardien de refuge
malgré le mauvais temps d'hier soir
l'hélicoptère a pu localiser un homme
c'est le guide qui encadrait le groupe
il est blessé mais vivant on a pu
retrouver la personne blessée sur la
neige et on a vu par là qu'ils avaient
de matériel il y avait beaucoup de
choses par là maintenant pas pu voir
d'autres survivants dans ce moment donc
comme elle en était en fin de journée on
n'a pas pu faire d'autre que trouillet
le blesser rentré à la base
transporté à l'hôpital d'aoste le guide
souffre de nombreux traumatismes à
l'abdomen et au thorax
il est conscient mais très choqué un
collègue qui a pu discuter avec lui
revient sur les circonstances de
l'accident qui nous bouffent évoluer
dans un terrain exposé un passage de
colle et une avalanche les emporter donc
laval qui s'est déclenché tout seul au
dessus de luxe u2 donc à un moment elle
est favorable
et puis voilà ils ont été emportés au
dessus d'une barre de
plusieurs dizaines de mètres est donc le
lead a survécu mais complètement
miraculeuse ion les corps des cinq
victimes une femme et quatre hommes ont
été redescendus dans la vallée
le guide quant à lui est toujours
hospitalisé ce soir il doit subir de
nouveaux examens demain et en attendant
les médecins réservent leur pronostic
malgré toutes les précautions les mises
en garde la montagne reste extrêmement
dangereux surtout lorsque les conditions
météorologiques sont mauvaises
aucun équipement aucune balise ne permet
d'éviter l'accident loïc de la mornais
et raymond chape l'art
ce jour là les secours arrivent en masse
mais trop tard sous cette coulée de
neige il y a un corps que les gendarmes
du secours en haute montagne recherche
frénétiquement dans une course contre la
montre
c'est un chien qui détectera le skieur
décédé et après 15 minutes où on a
d'énormes chances de trouver la personne
vivante
au-delà de ces 15 minutes bon il ya il
ya vraiment de chance des chances de
trouver la personne décédée
lorsqu'une avalanche se déclenche elle
peut dévaler une pente à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres heure pour un
skieur emporté
les conséquences sont épouvantables on
meurt soit
malheureusement de décès traumatique
soit de noyade soit aussi par le souffle
de l'avalanche pour une avalanche de
poudreuse c'est-à-dire type plaques à
vent par le souffle qui peut nous
projeter sur une barre rocheuse
rencontre bas etc
même s'il a eu de la chance
un skieur encore conscient est incapable
de se dégager seul et la neige va former
autour de lui une gangue gelé un
sarcophage privé d'air où il va
s'asphyxier autre danger classique en
fin d'hiver avec le redoux les ponts de
neige
c'est une couche de neige qui recouvre
une crevasse
avec le redoux la couche s'amincit le
piège et parfois invisible le poids de
skieur suffit à tout faire s'écrouler
les opérations de secours comme dans cet
exercice sont alors très compliqué
puisqu'il faut aller rechercher des
victimes dans un environnement hostile à
des dizaines de mètres de profondeur
pour éviter ces drames
il y a bien sûr l'équipement arv à une
balise que se doit de porter tout skieur
hors piste
plus récemment des ingénieurs ont mis au
point ce sac à dos airbags les tests
grandeur nature montre que ce dispositif
évite au ski et remporter de s'enfoncer
dans la neige
mais la prévention reste la meilleure
arme comme avec ce simulateur
d'avalanche où les skieurs hors-piste
réalise ce qu'ils encourent
c'est une violence inouïe
donc je pense que c'est dissuasif et
elle est un petit peu
du côté des avalanches pour les plus
récalcitrants reste la punition à
l'ancienne comme ce jour où les
secouristes ont dû aller rechercher 4
imprudent l'hélicoptère les a tirés
d'affaires mais redéposer en toute
sécurité tout juste quelques centaines
de mètres plus bas
pas de retour direct à la station et de
bonne heure de marche en chaussures de
ski pour méditer sur leur inconscience
nous retrouvons en direct italie benoît
gadret alors benoît vous êtes à cornier
devant l'hôpital où se trouvent les
corps des victimes et les enquêtes
commencent bien évidemment la justice
italienne s'est saisi de cet accident
les corps des cinq victimes ont été
transportées donc à la morgue de
l'hôpital qui se trouve derrière moi le
procureur du tribunal local le tribunal
livret à a nommé a désigné un expert en
l'occurrence un médecin légiste qui sera
chargée demain matin d'examiner les
corps des victimes
dans le même temps le guide rescapés
sera entendue soit par la police
italienne soit par le magistrat eux
directement les familles françaises donc
les familles des victimes ont été
autorisées par la justice italienne à se
recueillir devant le corps des défunts
ce sera probablement demain à la mi
journée
on en sait désormais davantage sur ses
victimes ce sont vous l'avez dit donc
quatre hommes et une femme âgés de 38 à
60 ans c'était des gens qui se
connaissaient qui était originaire de la
région parisienne la région de vichy
également de reims c'était des
alpinistes confirmés des amateurs
confirmés et expérimentés puisque il
avait réalisé une course au népal une
course réputée particulièrement
difficile quant au guide et bien c'est
un guide de la plagne en savoie et ce
guide accompagnait régulièrement ce
groupe d'amis merci benoît pour toutes
ces précisions
à paris plusieurs manifestations du 1er
mai aujourd'hui mais un peu moins de
monde que l'an dernier dans les cortèges
d'autres journées d'action cependant
sont prévues notamment le 15 et le 22
mai après force ouvrière ce matin
c'était cet après midi autour de la cgt
de la cfdt pour une fois côte à côte
deux défilés les mots d'ordre ont porté
sur le pouvoir d'achat et la réforme des
retraites
romain mi6 bruno vignes et et mathias
marbre
les manifestations et un brin de
nostalgie dans les rues de paris on
n'oublie pas les 40 ans de mai 68 mais
en tête des cortèges c'est l'actualité
qui s'imposent
la réforme des retraites et le passage à
41 ans de cotisations euros à loyer ses
4 500 euros
né via des clochards objet d aucun des
moyens
c'est pas normal qu'il ait lieu
continuer à bosser pendant que la
jeunesse est au chômage on est le seul
prévenu
pour emad akel à la défense des
retraites comme leitmotiv
mais les inquiétudes sont nombreuses
notamment sur le pouvoir d'achat
on se retrouve avec des gens qui
travaillent qui va s'ouvrir
on leur promet monts et merveilles il on
y va dans des conditions de travail très
difficiles
à paris ils étaient plus de 30000 dans
les rues force ouvrière fait cortège à
part ce matin mais la cgt et la cfdt
défilent côte-à-côte cet après-midi unis
le 1er mai du jamais vu depuis cinq ans
c'est ce qui nous donne un peu plus de
poids pour dire au gouvernement
notamment
il ne suffit pas de nous rencontrer de
nous recevoir maintenant il va falloir
nous entendre sur les revendications que
nous défendons en mai le temps des
manifestations n'est pas terminée les
syndicats donnent rendez vous le 15 aux
fonctionnaires le 22 contre la réforme
des retraites à marseille sur la
canebière les syndicats ont comptabilisé
30 mille personnes avec eux aussi défilé
les dockers et les agents portuaires qui
sont en grève donc à marseille depuis
maintenant trois semaines à grenoble
7000 personnes selon les syndicats ce
sont les lycéens qui conduisait le
le cortège est au total selon le
ministère de l'intérieur 120 mille
manifestants ont défilé sur l'ensemble
du territoire
aujourd'hui à cuba des centaines de
milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées place de la révolution alors
que le régime du nouveau président raul
castro appel à relancer l'économie
nationale
les trois salariés sans papiers que
rocio norris épicé de régularisation
était à l'honneur aujourd'hui
l'un d'eux était en tête du cortège des
syndicats ils ont largement profité de
ce congé du 1er mai qui marque pour eux
la fin d'une vie de clandestinité les
sept autres salariés du restaurant qui
sont dans le même cas de figure sont
provoquées lundi à la préfecture elle
espère aussi être régularisée selon les
syndicats au moins 900 demandes ont été
déposées pauline d'ordi et christophe
kenck
sa première carte de séjour en main ils
défilent fièrement en tête du cortège
depuis deux ans il travaillait et vivait
dans l'ombre pour lui ce 1er mai est
historique et comment ceux du restaurant
où ils travaillent tous avaient déposé
leur dossier en préfecture trois ont été
régularisés les demandes des sept autres
sont examinées au cas par cas
en attendant là-bas traoré a tenu à
remercier ce matin l'association qui les
a soutenus ainsi tu sais le gouvernement
a quand même donné un signe politique
favorable en régularisant déjà ces trois
travailleurs sans papiers qui sont
exactement dans le même cas que les 600
autres
il ya maintenant aucune raison pour que
tous ceux qui sont en grève depuis le 15
avril ne soit pas aussi régularisés en
tout près d'un millier de dossiers de
travailleurs sans papiers ont été
déposés dans les préfectures d'île de
france
le front national a aussi organisé son
rassemblement traditionnel au pied de la
statue de jeanne d'arc peu de monde dans
un contexte particulièrement difficile
pour le front miné par des problèmes
d'argent et des tensions internes
suscitées notamment par les derniers
propos de jean marie le pen qui revenu
sur le détail comme il aime à le dire
des chambres à gaz
thierry kurt et et jean-marc toc toc ce
matin avant le départ du défilé une
évidence seuls les plus motivés des
militants fait le déplacement cette
année
le front national est en crise
il est contraint de vendre son siège il
ne s'est pas redressée significativement
aux municipales de plus un nouveau
dérapage de jean marie le pen sur les
chambres à gaz
bouille toute tentative de
reconstruction marine le pen partisane
d'une voix qui normaliserait le front
national regrette à demi-mot le dérapage
de son père s'est pas pris mes distances
j'ai pas à prendre mes distances j'ai
dit je n'avais pas la même vision que
nuit sur les événements de la seconde
guerre mondiale le patron du front
national lui ne voit pas là de problèmes
vous n'avez pas peur que vos récentes
déclarations dans le magazine bretons
perd plus on veut l'image de 10,3 du
tout mais alors pas du tout pas de
contrition non plus dans son discours il
fait un bilan sombre d'une année de
présidence sarkozy
aucune des promesses célèbre solennelle
du candidat sarkozy n'a été tenue au
bout d'un an de sarkozysme la france est
au bord de la faillite économique
à 80 ans cette année jean marie le pen
ne laisse à personne le soin de fixer le
cas même si dans l'ombre certains
commencent à oser parler de succession
et puis l'hommage à la mémoire de brahim
bouarram sur le pont du carrousel à
paris en mai 1995 ce marocain de 30 ans
avait été jeté dans la seine par des
manifestants du front national bertrand
delanoë le maire de paris étaient
présents à cette cérémonie
nicolas sarkozy avec sa chapelle en
allemagne pour l'hommage angela merkel
qui a reçu le prix charlemagne pour tous
européen le président français a
beaucoup insisté sur la grande amitié
qui les lie sur le ton de la boutade
ecoutez-le la presse parle beaucoup de
notre coupe
je félicite monsieur merkel qui est là
je voudrais lui dire de ne pas croire
tout ce qui est écrit dans la presse
j'aime angela merkel beaucoup plus que
ce qu'ils disent au tchad un français de
49 ans travaillant pour l'association
humanitaire save the children a été tué
par balle près de la frontière
soudanaise son convoi a été stoppé par
des hommes armés alors qu'il revenait de
la région d'adré où il assurait le suivi
des enfants que l'arche de zoé avaient
tenté de soustraire à leurs familles
bernard kouchner a dénoncé je cite un
acte barbare et ignobles il demande aux
autorités de chad yens de faire toute la
lumière sur cette affaire
en italie l initiative intempestive du
ministère des finances qui est dit
villiers sur internet les 40 millions de
déclarations de revenus des italiens a
suscité un véritable tollé quelques
heures après cette malheureuse publicité
il autorités ont dû faire machine
arrière mais le mal est fait et beaucoup
maintenant on tue le temps de
télécharger plusieurs listes philippe
visseyrias et clara bosco l'espace d'un
clic un monde secret s'est entrouvert
hier sur le site de la direction des
impôts
les italiens ont pu consulter les
déclarations de revenus pour 2005 de
leurs voisins de leurs collègues de
bureau de leur patron de leurs hommes
politiques adresse personnelle comprise
raison invoquée par les services fiscaux
un souci de transparence à l'arrivée une
vraie pagaille le site était pris
d'assaut est saturé je trouve ça juste
que quelqu'un comme moi qui touche une
retraite de 800 euros par mois
sache combien d'impôts paye mon voisin
qui roulent en cas de quatre mois je
trouve que c'est une violation de la vie
privée dès 16h30 face aux protestations
l'autorité garante des libertés
individuelles a fait fermer le site et
interdire la diffusion via internet de
ces déclarations de revenus mettre les
données des contribuables sur un site
internet cela veut dire qu'on les rende
accessible dans le monde entier et qu'on
risque de les voir le quotidien la
stampa a eu le temps de noter de révéler
ce matin les revenus des personnalités
italiennes les plus en vue le plus riche
le couturier giorgio armani plus de 44
millions d'euros
silvio berlusconi qui n'a jamais fait
mystère de sa fortune 28 millions
d'euros 3 millions 5 pour le comédien
roberto benigni
et plus de 9 millions pour david
trezeguet le footballeur français de la
juventus de turin en italie il n'est pas
interdit de consulter une déclaration de
revenus tout citoyen peut en faire la
demande auprès des services fiscaux
auprès des communes une procédure
d'ordinaire très strictes qui n'a rien à
voir avec cette ruée sauvage sur
internet et en france aussi on peut
consulter le rôle des impôts c'est à
dire avant accès au registre du fisc
mais là encore il faut respecter des
procédures le faire dans un cadre précis
et sans publicité quelconque fabien
chanot pour connaître l'impôt de votre
voisin direction les services fiscaux de
votre département
la loi vous autorise à consulter la
liste des contribuables assujettis à
l'impôt sur le revenu ou à l'impôt sur
les sociétés elle vous permet aussi de
connaître le montant de l'impôt payé par
chaque contribuable ainsi que son revenu
imposable
seule contrainte vous n'avez accès
qu'aux dossiers des personnes qui
dépendent de la même perception que vous
ces informations ne sont pas
confidentiels mais il est interdit de
les dupliquer et de les diffuser
cependant il arrive qu'elle ne soit à la
suite d'un cafouillage des services
fiscaux il ya quelques années
plusieurs milliers de personnes
reçoivent leur avis d'imposition
mais en pages intérieures surprise
quelqu'un d'autre qui était derrière
à l'origine de ce couac une erreur de
l'imprimeur et puis il ya les fuites
dont peuvent être victimes les
célébrités
en 1989 la feuille d'impôt de jacques
calvet alors pdg de peugeot citroën fait
la une du canard enchaîné le journal
révélait la forte augmentation du patron
en plein conflit social sur les salaires
à partir de demain le smic augmente de
23 euros nets par mois et les
allocations familiales sont réformés
revue de détail avec cyril za 480 euros
sur un an
c'est le manque à gagner de cette
famille avec le nouveau mode de calcul
des allocations familiales
le supplément de 40 euros dont
bénéficiaient les néo disparaît l'aide
ne sera récupéré que lorsqu'il atteindra
ses 14 ans du coup le père ne décolère
pas tous les à-côtés bas ça ça aide
forcément un petit peu on ne peut pas
cracher dessus
et donc là une fois de plus la famille
est fracassée
c'est donc la fin des rallonges lorsque
l'enfant atteint l'âge de 11 et 16 ans
désormais une augmentation unique 60
euros au quatorzième anniversaire
autre changement conséquence directe de
la hausse des prix l'augmentation du
smic + 2,3 pour cent soit 23 euros net
de plus par mois
en hausse également mais plus dur pour
le porte-monnaie des ménages le prix du
gaz pour la deuxième fois depuis le
début de l'année les tarifs grimpent +5
5% sur votre facture
et parmi les thèmes de préoccupations
sociales la réforme des retraites et la
prise en compte de la pénibilité au
travail
un sujet que le ministre n'a pas inscrit
dans son projet de réforme
parmi les métiers les plus dangereux
celui de marins pêcheurs où chaque année
20 personnes trouvent la mort un sur
huit est touché par un accident du
travail
sortie en mer avec un équipage dans des
conditions vous allez le voir qu'ils
sont en effet particulièrement
difficiles reportage valérie le rouge et
thomas donzel
pour l'atlantique et pour la mer du nord
grands frais en cours pour diqing la
météo marine annonce des vents de force
6 à 7 des creux de quatre mètres
qu'importe trois heures trente hier
matin sur le port du guilvinec
patrice beunard rejoint ses deux mc
l'eau pour aller pêcher la langoustine
il y encore deux ans l'équipage n'aurait
pas pris le large avec pareille
prévisions alors d'aujourd'hui non pas
parce que le banquier qui cueillait qui
passe mauvais qu'il fasse beau en fait
et c'est pas trop son problème est que
la ressource fois rendez vous qu'elle ne
le soit pas non plus non on va essayer
que ça se passe en mules trois heures de
navigation plus tard l'océan est
toujours aussi agité le chalut est enfin
jeté durant plusieurs heures il est
tracté à 100 mètres de profondeur là où
se nichent les précieux crustacés
c'est bon le matin magritte en ya qui
peuvent pas chaud
au rang des rares qu'est-ce qu'on a
essentiellement là essentiellement des
langoustines
quelques sauts
expliquez moi quand vous êtes payés ou
vers des meilleurs résultats
on ne mange pas
avec les mouettes pour seule compagne le
bateau poursuit son voyage à trois
reprises le filet jeter à l'eau tirée
deux heures puis remonté il pèse
plusieurs centaines de kilos les
organismes sont mis à rude épreuve et
les marins n'arrête jamais les pêcheurs
ont échappé in extremis à la réforme des
régimes spéciaux ils ne cotisent
toujours que trente sept années et demie
mais ne se sentent pas pour autant
privilégier ses prétentions à contenir
appareils je crois que dans largement
gagné ça ne s'est pas démérité je pense
pas
ou alors celui qui dira sort
forcément il n'a jamais les pieds sur un
bateau mouche fois reçues
après 13 heures de mer le coup de vent
n'a pas faibli mais il en faudrait plus
pour priver les matelots d'une pause
saucisse frites
le seul moment de répit de la journée
retour au port du guilvinec l'un des
principaux ports de pêches de bretagne
où les marins sont chaque soir très
attendu direction la criée pour y
débarquer la quinzaine de caisse de
langoustines et de poissons des
restaurateurs de la région des
poissonniers et des acheteurs de grandes
surfaces ils font leur marché mais elle
a crié aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
crieur plus comme avant mais c'est vrai
que le bouton dernier qui lâche si elle
aussi vous voulez quoi quand ils m'ont
dit c'est le moins cher
quelques minutes plus tard le verdict
tombe
pour patrice beunard bandes actives en
2002 1200 euros dont l'objectif en
partie atteint 2200 euros qu'elle
patrice doit retirer 400 euros de gazole
pour la journée et presque autant pour
l'usure des deux villes et
l'amortissement du bateau le reste est
partagé entre membres de l'équipage ils
gagnent entre 2 et 3000 euros par mois
mais ils sont bien loin des 35 heures
pour beaucoup le mois de mai c'est aussi
l'occasion de s'évader le temps d'un
week-end la police s'étant
particulièrement présentes sur les
routes pour surveiller le comportement
des automobilistes
les contrôles sont généralisées et les
gendarmes en embuscade françois jullien
pieds-noirs et pascal caron les
gendarmes sont sur le pont aujourd'hui
le dispositif est en place depuis
seulement 2 minutes et déjà sur cette
autoroute un excès de vitesse
167 km heure les gendarmes retiendront
158 pour la marge d'erreur plus 90 euros
damende pour cet habitué de la vitesse
au jeu jouant comme ça qu'il s'est passé
une nouvelle fois pourquoi rodolphe donc
apparaître des retards qui ont la plus
de 110 kg général
lui kilomètres plus loin une autre
patrouille
rien qu'en seine-et-marne 140 gendarmes
sont déployés 30 contrôle installés
c'est deux fois plus qu'un jour normal
or beaucoup voilà nos forces
ça fait ralentir automobilistes lévy
circule le plus sereinement et
l'accident sur brad la circulation va
s'intensifier dans le sens des retours
samedi est classé orange en
ile-de-france et dans l'est
et ce sera rouge dimanche partout le
ministère des transports rappelle donc
quelques principes de base port de la
ceinture à l'avant et à l'arrière
respect de la vitesse de la distance
entre les véhicules et bien entendu pas
d'alcool au volant cuir à respecter
c'est le temps
le temps produite s'arrête pas toutes
les deux heures
c'est peut-être en partie grâce aux
contrôles renforcés qu'en 2007 le mois
de mai a été l'un des moins meurtrier de
l'année sur les routes
346 personnes sont mortes à cette
période aux états unis l'augmentation du
prix de l'essence inquiète son prix a
doublé en trois ans et qui conduit
certains des axes parfois pittoresques
parfois hautement répréhensibles comme
siphonner le réservoir du voisin
d'autres envisagent de revenir au moyen
de transport totalement typique
voyez ce reportage d'ariane roues et
aaron diamant il avait juré qu'à 4
dollars le gallon d'essence ou de diesel
il abandonnerait la voiture pour le
cheval chose promise chose due alan
pièce défilent donc dans les rues de
cette petite ville du kentucky en signe
de protestation contre la flambée des
prix du carburant
tout le monde pour nicher se plaint moi
j'essaie de faire quelque chose en
vérité à lang pierce n'est pas le seul à
protester les camionneurs premiers
touchés ont envahi les rues de
washington le week-end dernier avec leur
impressionnant engin
ici le diesel est plus cher que
l'essence et même si le prix du litre 70
75 centimes d'euros peut paraître
raisonnable vu d'europe
il grignote la marge de ces
professionnels baisser le prix du gasoil
fait quelque chose ça se répercute sur
tout le monde transport nourriture toute
l'économie
première conséquence la réapparition et
l'explosion d'une criminalité oublier le
siphonage des stations service des
réservoirs de camions ou des citernes de
ferme c'est de l'or de l'or liquide
voilà ce que c'est quand c'était à 30
centimes le litre personne ne pensait
même à le voler mais maintenant cette
crise du carburant ne fait toutefois pas
que des malheureux
les prêteurs sur gages en particulier
font des affaires en or en ce moment
tout le monde manque d'argent et les
banques ne prêtent pas et galop alors
ils viennent emprunter 50 $ pour faire
le plein pop mais en fait c'est toute la
société américaine qui est touché une
société où l'on fait couramment 100 km
par jour pour se rendre à son travail
la hausse du prix de l'essence agit donc
comme une ponction intolérable sur les
classes moyennes à londres début du vote
pour l'élection municipale ce matin le
maire sortant camille kingston appelé
les londoniens se mobiliser son
concurrent le plus sérieux le
conservateur boris johnson a été
applaudi par une foule nombreuse pour
une fois elle a choisi le registre de la
sobriété on connaîtra demain le nom du
vainqueur
en israël ce matin pendant deux minutes
les sirènes ont figé le pays c'est le
moment le plus poignant de cette journée
dédiée à la mémoire des six millions de
juifs victimes de l'holocauste dans tout
le pays les sirènes ont retenti à 10
heures précises et tous les habitants se
sont immobilisés dans un recueillement
collectif en france le commissariat à
l'énergie atomique va construire un
super calculateur pour le programme
nucléaire français
ce sera le pétaflops une immense machine
à calculer qui représente plusieurs
centaines de mètres carrés est capable
d'effectuer un million de milliards
d'opérations par seconde patrice pollet
en est tout retourné
à première vue ça ressemble à des
armoires électriques
en réalité c'est un calculateur il
permet de réaliser virtuellement
l'explosion de la bombe atomique
française matérialisé par ces chiffres
sur cet écran est ainsi de se passer des
céréales avec soixante mille milliards
d'opérations par seconde
c'est l'un des plus puissants du monde
mais en 2010 dans cette salle il sera
remplacé par une autre machine encore
plus puissante
un calculateur pétaflopique nous visons
une puissance installée de l'orme du
pétaflops
c'est à dire un million de milliards
d'opérations par seconde
si on veut regarder de plus en plus des
zones très particulière dans le
fonctionnement larmes
on est obligé par définition d'augmenter
notre puissance de calcul des
calculateurs pétaflopique tous les
chercheurs en rêve pour modéliser ce
tremblement de terre cinq mille
milliards de calculs par seconde ont été
nécessaires c'est une modélisation
complète de l'ensemble des phénomènes
depuis la rupture le tremblement de
terre lui même la propagation et la
sollicitation du bâtiment dans ses
structures et en médecine
nous avons aussi besoin de
l'hyperpuissance des calculateurs pour
mieux détecter les tumeurs cancéreuses
typiquement si vous me donner accès à
une machine en fois plus puissantes que
celles auxquelles on a accès au jour
d'aujourd'hui
au lieu de faire la simulation d'un
patient je pourrais peut être faire dix
patients par jour voire même plus en 69
pour se poser sur la lune
le calculateur d'apollo 11 des pinces et
à peine la puissance d'une calculatrice
de poche à guise dans l'aisne existe
depuis le 19e siècle sorte de palais
social vaste bâtiment d'habitation
construit par l'industriel jean baptiste
godin l'inventeur du poil du même nom
pour loger ses ouvriers cet édifice
unique est toujours habité par une
centaine de personnes
il est en cours de rénovation visite
guidée avec il junca et mathias ou le
temple du travail c'est le familistère
godin en 1859 le célèbre industriel
inventeur du poêle en fonte décide de
bâtir un palais social
500 appartements pour loger les
travailleurs de son usine
son idée c'était avec le lait produit du
travail des ouvriers mais c'était de
leur rendre les équivalents de la
richesse de l'air de l'espace de la
lumière l'eau à tous les étages et même
un système de climatisation
les appartements sont spacieux avec
cabinet de toilette et bien sûr
cuisinière en fonte
un luxe pour l'époque c'est tellement
évolué c'est même limite plus évolués
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'on
régresse aujourd'hui les gens se
connaissaient tous vivaient la même vie
il n'y avait pas de distinction sociale
tout le monde avait le droit ou même
équivalent de la richesse et tout le
monde se connaissait évidemment
puisqu'il se faisait parfois plusieurs
générations que les gens a dit ici étant
donné aussi que les retraités continuent
à vivre ici en 1878 le familistère
abrite plus de 1000 personnes
ces habitants oublié ou directeurs en
sont propriétaires tout comme l' usine
leurs enfants vont à l'école ensemble il
y à un théâtre et même une piscine
gaudin leur a tout donné le familistère
n'est pas une société ouvrière ces
sociétés pour tout le monde
jean baptiste andré godin habite le
familistère comme les directeurs de
lusine leur contremaître les ouvriers
c'est société équitable et solidaire
entre les classes démocratique et
solidaire
la société du familistère a vécu plus
d'un siècle un siècle de célébration du
travail le mont-saint-michel inaugure ce
jeudi de l'ascension les cérémonies les
versèrent de sa fondation il ya 1300 ans
ce haut lieu de pèlerinage avant d'être
une des destinations touristiques les
plus connues au monde est aussi une
abbaye romual bonnan et galeries et
lequel il sur son îlot rocheux et aux
confins de la normandie et de la
bretagne
l'abbaye est visible à plus de 50
kilomètres à la ronde le
mont-saint-michel témoin d'une présence
chrétienne entrer ici depuis l'an 700
treize siècles traversée que des
pèlerins venus de toute la france
célèbre à partir d'aujourd'hui en
commençant par ses rentes et sur les
marches de ce sanctuaire unique faut
être costaud pour monter là haut c'est
l'ascension aujourd'hui en plus on fête
l'anniversaire du mont saint michel
c'est doublement symbolique
entre ciel et terre le mont saint michel
et son abbaye premier site français
classé sur la liste du patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
un sanctuaire où au fil du temps se sont
empilées tous les styles du moyen-âge au
19ème avec au sommet le cloître et ce à
double rangée de colonnes la vie plus
beaux exemples de l'architecturé
monastique en 1300 ans il ya des
mentalités radicalement différente des
spiritualités radicalement différente d
architecture radicalement différente et
le mont saint michel est la somme de
toutes là l'histoire du mont saint
michel les personnes qui désirent faire
le tour propre été visitée avant l'heure
du repas pas étonnant alors que le
mont-saint-michel soit devenu le
troisième site le plus visité de france
après la tour eiffel le château de
versailles chaque année trois millions
de touristes toujours sous le charme du
lieu est sublime c'est magnifique c'est
c'est reposant c'est très verdoyant
je souffle coupé parce que c'est
vraiment magnifique c'est un rêve depuis
tout le temps et c'est fait
l'anniversaire du mont saint michel avec
au programme randonnée pèlerinage et
concerts des festivités qui vont durer
jusqu'en novembre 2009 on a pas mille
trois cents ans tous les jours
la chine multiplie les efforts pour
terminer au plus tôt les 37 sites
olympiques avant le début des jeux il
aura fallu me chantier 29 milliards
d'euros pour financer ses nouvelles
installations comme celle de qingdao à
900 km au sud est de pékin station
balnéaire de 7 millions d'habitants qui
doit accueillir les compétitions de
voile
reportage sur place samah soula et
tristan le bras
un petit air d'europe du nord sur la mer
jaune xinmao a gardé les traces d'un
siècle de concessions allemandes les
chinois adorent c'est la station
balnéaire où ils viennent voir la mer
pour la première fois à la belle saison
la plage devient un studio photo très
prisé des futurs mariés 10 heures de
train parfois juste pour prendre la pose
la rome antique china au mérite et donc
de figurer dans les villes olympiques
non sans quelques retouches épreuve de
voile oblige l'ancien chantier naval est
devenue une marina on a regroupé le
village olympique et le site de
compétition c'est plus pratique glycines
deux bâtiments rutilant de 17 étages la
résidence des sportifs après les jo ce
sera un hôtel cinq étoiles vous êtes les
premiers visiteurs
vous êtes très chanceux premier visiteur
n'est pas seul les journalistes chinois
sont également de la visite guidée
intarissable sur la modernité des lieux
ici les stores électriques plus de 800
athlètes seront reçus ici et on tient à
les bichonner
là c'est le barreau pourront se reposer
les fonctionnaires et les athlètes comme
ça ils seront plus performants sur la
jetée
les ouvriers s'affairent à installer des
éoliennes la fierté écologique de ce
site olympique même si elles sont en
nombre symbolique
la chine veut offrir un visage sans
faille qingdao fournit donc de brigades
de planteurs de verdure même frénésie
sur les chantiers grue et béton doit
disparaître pour ce quartier les jo sont
une aubaine
grâce à eux une rue ville du sport a
remplacé un paysage beaucoup moins
présentables
avant ici c'était des égouts c'était
très sale
regardez ce que c'est devenu à l'image
du shintô les cinq autres villes
olympiques n'ont lésiné sur aucun moyen
pour que la vitrine soit parfaite
au moment des jo aucun détail ne doit
venir contrarier la démonstration de la
puissance chinoise football en ligue des
champions chelsea s'est imposé face à
liverpool 3 à 2 c'est drogba qui a
ouvert le score pour chelsea égalisé par
fernando torres lors des prolongations
et non par a redonné l'avantagé chaînes
font suivi d'un second but de drogba
c'est donc celle ci qui rencontrera
manchester en finale avant de refermer
ce journal je vous rappelle la
principale information les six des
listes français qui se trouvaient dans
les alpes italiennes 3000 mètres
d'altitude ont été victimes d'une
avalanche qui les a projetés contre une
barre rocheuse hier après midi
cinq ont été retrouvées mortes au jour
encore dès le 6e qui a pu être secouru
hier soir est toujours à l'hôpital
les familles des victimes sont attendus
en italie c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo de tanya lyons suivi du point
route de julien pascal matters 50 vue du
ciel avec yann arthus-bertrand demain
pour l'information pour retrouverez et
les us et à 13h excellente soirée sur
france 2 ce soir
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr